a free volume that was distributed to
people who attended the film red
screenings in Japan revealed that 38
years ago Goldie Roger found a
one-year-old Shanks inside a treasure
chest on God Valley multiple Celestial
dragons were present on God Valley at
that time which is part of the reason
why the island was attacked in film red
the gorosei implied that Shanks is a
member of a powerful family known as the
figure land family so we know that
Shanks is a member of a prominent family
that the Goro say are aware of we know
he was found as a baby on God Valley
where multiple Celestial dragons were
present and we know that Shanks is able
to easily infiltrate marijua and gain a
private audience with the gorosei
despite being one of the most notorious
pirates in the world now it all makes
sense because Shanks is a Celestial
Dragon just like the gorosei if you want
more one-piece content do me a favor and
subscribe right now